pope francis has called europe's neglect
of refugees a shipwreck of civilization
urging governments to do more to protect
them the probe is visiting migrants on
the greek island of lesbos where more
than 2 000 people are living in a for
asylum seekers he's repeatedly
highlighted the plight of refugees
throughout his papacy
and dw correspondent max sander is
standing by for us at the camp which
pope francis has just left
max what did the pope have to say
well nick the pope really didn't beat
around the bushes he made very clear in
his own way that changes had to happen
in europe and in the rest of the world
with regards to migration
firstly he thanked the people here in
greece on all levels from community
volunteers to the authorities who led a
helping hand in
in
working on the migration crisis here but
he also said since the last time he
visited five years ago not much has
changed greece is still on its own
greece is pretty much isolated and
dealing with the problem by itself while
other european countries that's what he
said are pretending that this issue
migration is none of their concern and
this uh results in some of the uh events
that we're seeing around europe now that
that barriers are being built that
fences are being built that pushbacks
are happening at the eu's external
borders and pope francis made clear that
this is not the answer he was calling
for political action and for wide range
of policies to change this
i understand you're standing right next
to the tent where the pope made that
speech in the refugee center
what was the reaction from the migrants
who heard him speak
yeah so um let me tell you when the pope
walked into that tent right over there
so it's 50 meters from where i'm
standing right now um a choir of the
west african migrants started singing
and they sang for quite a few minutes uh
and it was a very touching very
heartwarming beautiful moment a moment
of joy that you don't really have often
in places like this or like moria camp
the the the former campbell
[ __ ] camp where we're here
right now um so you could interpret this
as a sign of hope perhaps but uh the
people who i talk to um they have hope
they they they they hope that uh this
sends an important signal but they are
also very aware of the difficult
situation that they're in they
appreciate that somebody like pope
francis is standing up for them but at
the same time they know that many many
others far more don't
okay well um
max as you know lesbos became a symbol
of the refugee crisis and europe's
struggle to deal with it you've of
course been on the island for a few days
talking to residents and to migrants of
course
about how things might be changing since
the crisis all began in 2015. let's have
a quick look at what you found out
the island of lesbos
a haven of tranquility with a rich
culture and a long history
aphrodite fatih
calls lesbos her home
last year her family started renting out
these bungalows to tourists hoping more
people would come back to visit
in 2015 the island became a migration
hotspot for hundreds of thousands hoping
for a better life in europe
it was extremely
difficult and challenging uh for us
and we never knew when this was going to
stop also so that was scary and we also
knew that we were helping and we knew
that we were going to pay a consequence
some kind of consequence for this at one
point
the following year tourism was down 80
percent many firms went out of business
to take pressure off the islands the
government transferred thousands of
people to the mainland today just over
two thousand people live here in the
mavervuni camp a fraction of the numbers
that used to crowd the island's previous
accommodation facility just two years
ago
despite decreasing numbers lifeview
remains very difficult
since the beginning of the pandemic
residents have only been allowed to
leave the camp once or twice a week
i cannot get good sleep i cannot get
good food i cannot get
good time so
all my time in the day all my time in
the day it's very bad because of the
situation
salat from somalia has been living in
the camp for nine months while he waits
for a decision on his asylum case he and
others are likely to be moved to another
facility soon
camps like this one which recently
opened on the island of samos are part
of the government's new strategy
improving living conditions while at the
same time keeping residents behind
fences and barbed wire
the same strategy is planned for lesbos
for very long islanders have been
resisting plans to construct a permanent
closed facility here in lesbos but after
years of arguing an agreement was
finally made to build it here
in the middle of nowhere far away from
any city or village
many islanders are still against the
planned camp
for businesswoman africifati mariola
finding a sustainable solution must
include the local population she says
it's time to show a different side of
lesbos
the stigmatization of the islands that
bear the the weight of the refugee
crisis needs to stop
we need the truth to come out there and
we need to people to realize how
beautiful and how blessed lesbos island
this is to come and see it for
themselves
for everyone here on the island the
dream of a better future remains strong
and max your report mentioned greece's
new island detention camp are they
really an improvement i mean especially
considered from the migrants perspective
um well the idea of these close
permanent camps was introduced a few
years ago when there was a large refugee
migrant population here on the island 20
000 people living in very difficult
conditions now this is this has changed
um due to depopulating the island due to
the government bringing people to the
mainland so um
right now there might be a chance for
these camps to go ahead though um we
know that uh there's still some uh some
controversy around these camps and a lot
of people not just ngos resisting them
for the um for living conditions that
are very harsh on the population
all right uh thanks for that dw
correspondent max zander on lesbos where
pope francis has just paid a visit
you